[Musique]
benjamin franklin et la fabrication d'un
faux journal afin de gagner la guerre
d'indépendance américaine
[Musique]
nous sommes en 1782 liqueur de la guerre
d'indépendance américaine et une époque
où la situation n'est pas rose pour les
révolutionnaires
benjamin franklin se trouve alors à
paris en france
il a même amené sa propre presse
imprimée il cherche à obtenir des appuis
des têtes couronnées européennes afin
d'avoir de l'argent et des militaires
pour l'aider à gagner la guerre
d'indépendance
il a donc une idée ils vont imprimer la
copie parfaite d'un journal très réputé
de la nouvelle angleterre se trouve à
boston l'indépendant tchango mais jamais
franck réussit alors à faire une copie
presque parfaite dudit journal et publie
une nouvelle qui va choquer les grandes
cour européenne est choquée en fait les
habitants de la nouvelle angleterre la
nouvelle va se répandre comme une
traînée de poudre
il annonce en fait que le roi
d'angleterre et allié des autochtones de
la côte est de l'amérique du nord et que
ces derniers ont tué plus de 700 hommes
femmes et enfants et ont mis les scalps
dans des sacs afin de les offrir en
cadeau au roi d'angleterre
il n'en fallait pas plus pour que la
réaction soit très forte en europe
les gens sont dégoûtés et très
rapidement même les journaux de nouvelle
angleterre entre autres à new york et
même à boston vont reprendre la nouvelle
et c'est ainsi que benjamin franklin va
réussir à avoir un peu plus d'argent et
de nouveaux militaires afin de gagner la
guerre d'indépendance
un an plus tard benjamin franklin est
donc compris le pouvoir de la presse on
pouvait utiliser les journaux surtout
leur crédibilité afin de répondre une
fausse rumeur et pouvoir gagner une
guerre d'indépendance
[Musique]